talk to us about the difference between
the bitcoin spot etf and the bitcoin
futures etf i know that there's a ton of
debate as to whether the spot etf should
have gotten approved first or the
futures we get the future so what is the
key differences between those two
structures
yeah i could start so i'll say like as
we talk about this the big the big thing
here is it's moved from zero to one so
like while we are we think a spot a
product would be better for retail
investors probably um just because it's
less confusing
as we mentioned this is zero to one for
the sec which is a big move but it's not
necessarily going to have a massive
impact the other thing that i wanted to
go back to is eric talked about 24
trillion investor in advisor assets um i
mean even if you take a tiny tiny sliver
of that that's a lot of money that's
going into bitcoin whether it's the
futures etf or the spot etf
but the big difference here is futures
you have to roll every month so if
you're holding the front month contract
right that expires so the next one
expires on october 29th you need to sell
that contract that's going to expire on
october 29th and buy the next contract
that is november which is november 30th
whatever whenever the contract ends so
basically what happens is in a typical
market like with oil and other things
there's storage costs so that next
contract is usually more expensive
that's called contango so what you're
doing is you're selling the lower price
contract and buying the higher price so
every time you're losing a tiny bit of
money
and that can add up over the last year
that was about 36 percent um so i mean
it's it's not nothing um but we think we
expect that to go down and eric and i
actually had a call this morning with
mike mcglone who's some people on here
probably know he's um our commodity
analyst and he covers bitcoin as well
and he thinks that's going to go way
down so right now there's times where
contango is acting more like
a commodity that's hard to store like
oil and something like that that it's
hard to get this arbitrage because what
you can do is it's called a cash and
carry trade you essentially are going to
buy spot and sell the futures and
essentially you can earn that difference
when the the futures contract that's
coming up is more expensive um but right
it's not that expensive to store bitcoin
and get bitcoin like it is to go store
barrels of oil um so we think it's just
going to be armed away eventually um
which but even still i mean right now
we're talking about 10 to 12 percent on
average the last year or two i think um
but mike mcglone thinks it could go down
to half that five to six percent which
again isn't perfect obviously a spot
bitcoin etf doesn't have any of those
roll costs but for five to six percent
um for some of these people who are
going to be using these products
especially traders um in any long along
that lines um it's not that big of a
deal probably
and and let me a couple points here so
if you look at the pro funds mutual fund
that tracks bitcoin futures it's
basically the prequel to veto it's
already been out two and a half months
it's given us a nice case study for what
beta will do
it's only missed bitcoin by about 1 60
basis points in two and a half months
that's very good it's way better than we
thought it sort of feeds into mcglone's
prediction that the role was only bad
going way back
and that going forward especially with
the incentive to arb and how the etf
will bring all this money in uh we're
looking at it's probably more optimistic
than we originally thought and i but
still let's say it's five percent a year
if something costs you five percent here
that's kind of an annoying high fee
the other thing is advisors
who you know it's possible if this thing
tracks really well over long periods it
could bring in some of those advisors
but remember they're once bitten twice
shy a lot of advisors bought vxx and
learned the hard way what role costs are
that's like 40 a year vxx is brutal uh
uso could be 20 a year so they probably
are ung there's a couple of them where
they probably learn the hard way that
anything that rolls futures is
is could really um you could get the bet
right you could actually bet right on
oil or natural gas and actually not win
because of the product you chose that's
a big reputational sort of thing that
these etfs will have to overcome that
said the ability to track bitcoin on a
daily and weekly basis is all that will
matter to the trading crowd and that's a
real audience and that's fine there are
etfs that are for traders and some that
are for long term
the question is can this one actually
build its audience beyond the trading
crowd and that roll cost will be a big
uh you know variable in that
when you guys think about the grayscale
uh bitcoin trust gbtc uh it now has been
confirmed that they're going to apply to
have it converted to the spot etf do we
think that uh just odds have increased
now because features have been approved
but we don't know much more than that or
do you guys have other thoughts around
uh that application and the potential
for it to be approved
okay i'll go uh so i i think well as i
mentioned this is zero to one for the
sec right so this is them and and as
people have talked about i mean a lot of
people out there um they talk about uh
no need for an etf uh their people are
mad at
gensler because of he's so negative
towards crypto but honestly he knows his
stuff like as much as people want to say
that he doesn't he really does know his
stuff and he's learning and i i really
think that as we mentioned i think the
spot product is a better product for
most people that want to use this i
think they should have allowed both at
the same time uh and let investors put
their money where they want to put their
money right let them democrat let
democracy pick the the winning structure
uh but for whatever reason genzler chose
this he uh he highlights a few things so
one of the things is these futures
products are under something called the
1940 act and we don't need to get the
nitty-gritty here but like essentially
it's a little bit there's a little more
consumer investor protections there's a
little more restrictions on what you can
and can't do
versus something under the 1933 act
which is an older act that gbtc if it
converts and these other spot products
which we have a bunch of filings out for
uh they would fall into that 1933 act so
that's a big difference but again i
think the the part of the reason that
gensler went with this first is one
there's obviously some animosity in
congress uh janet yellen doesn't like
bitcoin
from
everything we've seen so i think this is
almost like uh cyoa like a little bit of
gensler covering himself because he can
say hey we slowed the roll uh we went
with futures which are already on a
regulated market by the cftc um i didn't
allow it right away we're taking your
time so i think this is just him like if
anything goes wrong he has all these
cushions between him uh whether bitcoin
gets cut 70 people lose their money
which obviously is possible to happen
we've seen happen plenty of times so i
think there's a whole bunch of reasons
why we went this route but i do think
we're going to see a conversion at some
point i just don't know if it's going to
be on gbc's first try and a little bit
of background so van neck is they filed
for this so the whole process for those
1940 act etfs was a whole different
scenario which is why a lot of people
weren't with eric and i when we were
calling for an october approval
initially because they go through a
different process where it's just a
75-day period gbtc and these other
physical etfs have to go through a
separate process there's something
called a 19b4 application they basically
need to apply to the exchange and ask
for a rule change to allow these etfs to
trade um
so that process
that's where you're used to hearing all
this like delay or deny or approve and
all the other filings we've seen they
either delayed or approve so they go
45-day process delay or
delay or approve delay or approve and it
adds up to 240 days and that's after
they get this 19b4 application to hit
the what's called the sec register so
bitwise filed one on friday and it
hasn't hit the register yet but after it
hits that register then you have
basically 240 days uh before the sec
needs to make a decision um and we have
vanx spot etf that they filed through
the 1933 act on that 19b4 process and
their final date of approval from filing
on december 30th of 20 i think around
december 3rd depending on the exact date
2020 is november 11th so it's a long
time before they can be approved so even
if gb2c applies for this application
it's not that 75 day process i believe
it's going to be that 240 day post 19 b4
process so it's going to be a long time
even if they get approved the first time
and we don't think any of these etfs
that are coming up on this approval
window in this quarter are going to get
approved by the sec because they were
very very explicit in wanting a 1940x
product that only holds futures yeah
let me um let me jump in here because
yes it's a different process it takes
longer the heart of the matter though is
the problem for gbtc converting is it
would have to convert to a 33 act fund
and gensler does not like that act he is
really not into it he likes the 40 act
it has a a myriad of more investor
protection so as james said it's it's a
cya kind of act
uh he feels much more comfortable with
it so
the question you have to ask yourself
yes there's all these other technical
delays whatever but is when will gary
gensler get comfortable with the 33 act
or is it possible somehow bitcoin is
denoted as security because that means
it could then go under the 40 act
because you have to be a security to get
under that act so which of those two
things happened i just don't see either
of those things happening in any in the
near term even with and then you add on
the other delays and i just i don't know
i
i feel like um you're gonna hear a lot
of
talk about a conversion but
the question if you hear anybody say
this in your show
ask them well do you are you saying that
gary gensler is now comfortable with the
1933 act that's the question they won't
be able to answer